Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
La musica, voi, quando andate ai concerti,
la ascoltate con quel meraviglioso organo
che noi abbiamo, l'udito:
voi ascoltate, la musica.
E come ascoltate la musica?
Ascoltate un discorso che fa qualcuno:
però ben sapete che spesso, noi,
stiamo ascoltando qualcuno
però stiamo pensando altrove.
Succede la stessa cosa con la musica.
La musica voi la mettete in casa
per fare i lavori di casa;
vi fa da colonna sonora
mentre fate un viaggio.
Però non sentite la musica,
quella cosa meravigliosa che abbiamo noi,
nel nostro corpo, nel nostro fisico,
che è il sentire, le vibrazioni
che la musica dà.
Ed è per questo
che a me piacerebbe, con voi,
condividere questo sentire della musica.
E mi piacerebbe tanto
che voi, a un certo punto, mi dimostriate
che anche voi come noi,
agonisti, in questo caso, della musica,
sentite come noi la musica.
La musica dentro di noi
ce l'avete da quando siamo nati,
nella pancia della nostra mamma,
sapete il "tum-tum-tum",
sentiamo il cuoricino nostro.
Poi, man mano che cresciamo,
i suoni che ci vengono dati da fuori,
al di là di tutte le viscere,
lì, oltre le cose
che si muovono in pancia:
tutto quello è il ritmo,
tutto quello è sound,
sono suoni con cui noi cresciamo.
A questo io mi riferisco,
quando dico di "sentire" la musica,
e non soltanto ascoltare la musica.
Perché la musica ce l'abbiamo tutti.
La musica c'è nel vento, c'è nel passo:
quando camminiamo, c'è il ritmo.
Questo è un ritmo, che poi
diventa anche un balletto;
noi balliamo ma da dove veniamo?
Veniamo da un passo.
È questo, se vogliamo andare
nella storia dell'umanità,
nella storia della musica,
tutto viene da questi signori,
che sono i nostri antenati,
che con il femore di un mammut
hanno iniziato a "drum-drin-brum"
e l'altro ha iniziato a fare il passetto
e da lì sono nati i balli,
sono nati i ritmi
che poi portarono, nel corso
della storia dell'umanità,
alla musica che oggi,
come ben sapete, si è evoluta.
Ma c'è nel vento, c'è nella pioggia,
c'è in ogni elemento che ci circonda.
Ed è per questo che io considero
che non ci siano confini,
rispettando il tema di questa sera,
non ci siano confini
tra il tecnico e il biologico.
La musica ce l'abbiamo tutti.
Questa è una considerazione
molto personale:
che però ho constatato con tanti allievi
che ho avuto nel corso della mia carriera.
Se io vi dimostro, adesso, un fatto:
di sentire la musica
rispetto agli elementi della natura,
agli elementi che abbiamo dentro -
vi ho dimostrato il passo,
un vento, una pioggia -
e capite quanta musica c'è intorno a noi,
ma non ce ne siamo mai accorti.
Perché se voi studiate,
ascoltate e sentite la musica
venite anche a conoscenza
delle qualità interiori biologiche
che vi ha concesso la natura
e che, semplicemente,
non avete sviluppato.
Questa è una considerazione
personalissima,
che adesso vi porterò a dimostrare.
(Musica)
Volete un consiglio?
Mi piacerebbe che adesso vi liberiate.
Appoggiate per terra tutte le borse.
Sedetevi dritti.
Distendete le braccia,
proprio per aria, seduti
e intorno al corpo, così.
Esatto.
Chiudete gli occhi, e sentite la musica.
Immaginate il panorama
che volete, ma sentite -
Com'è stato il viaggio?
(Applausi)
A questo mi riferisco,
quando dico di sentire la musica,
non di ascoltarla fisicamente e basta.
A questo mi riferisco.
Sapete, noi abbiamo dei battiti cardiaci
che hanno delle velocità,
BPM si chiamano, battiti per minuto.
A seconda della velocità di un brano
ci portano in una sensazione,
in un'emozione, o in un'altra.
Ed è per questo che è importante,
quando si è sotto ansia,
mettere un pezzo lento, disteso;
o quando ci si vuole caricare,
quando si è in palestra,
mettere dei pezzi magari
un pelino più carichi.
Ed è per questo che a me
piacerebbe adesso dimostrare a voi
che questi limiti
non ci sono, nella musica.
Sono solo delle scelte.
Chi sceglie di seguire la musica
per mestiere, lavoro,
approfondendo la tecnica, teoricamente;
e c'è, invece, chi preferisce
solo tenerla come diletto.
Come ben sapete, la musica è ovunque:
c'è nella nostra quotidianità,
negli eventi, nelle cerimonie,
matrimoni, battesimi, feste di compleanno;
c'è in tutte le campagne politiche.
Se non ci fosse un inno,
non ci sarebbe una campagna politica,
magari con cui ci possiamo riconoscere.
O piuttosto, le religioni.
Un giorno facevo una battuta con un amico:
"Immagina il mondo senza musica,
immagina il mondo - perfino la Chiesa.
Immagina la Chiesa senza i cori,
senza tutte le sue messe con la musica. "
E questo amico, questo collega,
mi rispose: "Non ci crederebbe nessuno.
Alla Chiesa senza musica
non ci crederebbe nessuno."
Ed è per quello che io considero
che la musica fa parte di tutti noi.
E io invito voi a sentire la musica,
perché non ci sono limiti.
Ci sono delle barriere culturali
per cui siamo nati in una
o in un'altra geografia.
Ma oggi quei limiti non ci sono più.
Ed è per questo che io
vorrei portarvi, adesso,
su questo lato, diciamo,
chiamiamolo "teorico".
E mi piacerebbe che voi,
con me, faceste questo:
che io determino la dimostrazione
che quello che è stato detto stasera
è stato da voi assorbito
e voi mi dimostrerete che così è stato.
(Musica)
All right!
All right, ancora!
Ancora.
A questo mi riferisco,
a questo mi riferisco.
Avete dimostrato
che avete sentito la musica.
E quello che ho detto prima,
lo avete sentito.
Grazie Venezia. Grazie Mestre.
Grazie.
(Applausi)